entrer dans un univers ou soigné demande
de l'empathie et un certain sang-froid
comme un surveillance des différentes
endroits de l'unité via caméra l'unité
des psychiatries sécurisée parce que
plusieurs patients sont très instables
on a aussi des patients qui sont en
détention à l'hôpital parce que nous ont
été référés de l'Institut Pinel sans en
attente de passer devant la Commission
d'examen des troubles mentaux attendre
le feu vert des tribunaux pour garder ou
même traité des patients c'est une
constante dans le travail du psychiatre
Fouad serre que vous avez fait vos
médicaments vous êtes toujours vous
refusez toujours de les prendre cette
patiente refuse de prendre les
médicaments moi c'est la cour qui va
décider mais moi je pense que vous avez
besoin de prendre vos médicaments madame
ici plusieurs patients sont hospitalisés
sans qu'on ait le droit de leur
administrer la médication même si
plusieurs sont en psychose et qu'ils ont
donc perdu le contact avec la réalité il
faut toujours quand même avoir une
distance de sécurité être sur ses gardes
se dirige vers la chambre d'un jeune
qu'il veut garder plus longtemps le
patient fait irruption dans le corridor
il faudra trois personnes pour maîtriser
le jeune homme en détresse
[Musique]
plusieurs médicaments même restent
toujours tes agitée
elle était en garde en établissement je
viens de demander une prolongation de la
gare les délais pour ce genre de demande
sont passés de quelques semaines à
plusieurs mois parce que les tribunaux
sont engorgés de l'engorgement des
palettes de justice là puis de la
magistrature c'est vrai que les
ordonnances de traitement depuis trois
quatre ans les délais ont beaucoup
augmenté donc ça crée des
hospitalisations de deux trois quatre
mois sans qu'on puisse traiter le
patient vous êtes comme vous le savez
vous êtes comme en détention à l'hôpital
jusqu'à la décision de tribunal ici
environ 5% des listes est occupés par
des patients en attente d'une décision
d'un tribunal un problème surtout que
depuis le début de la pandémie la
demande augmente en psychiatrie 4 ans on
avait 7 à 8 consultes en psychiatrie à
Laval quand on arrivait le matin là
maintenant on est rendu à 15 16 de plus
il manque ici une douzaine de
psychiatres on devrait être 31
psychiatre
en rôle maintenant à 18 il portrait
semblable dans la région voisine dès
Laurentides pourtant le nombre de
psychiatres a augmenté au Québec depuis
10 ans mais plusieurs bouts de carrément
le travail en hôpital l'enjeu c'est que
là c'est psychiatres trouve ça tellement
exigeant dans le réseau hospitalier qui
ont tendance à quitter j'ai une
diminution de 8 % dans le réseau
hospitalier à la Cité de la santé de
Laval en plus il faudrait doubler le
nombre de lits un problème présent dans
plusieurs autres régions qui ajoutent à
la pression un psychiatre